babe got a brand new hour of stand-up
material May 5th Buffalo first show sold
out second Show tickets May 6 Ithaca has
tickets May 7th Albany all sold out May
28th Newport Rhode Island the second
show has some tickets left and then
September 22nd in New York Radio City
sold out September 23rd theater at
Madison Square Garden we have tickets my
big New York City shows I will not be in
the New York area other than those two
shows and Sydney Australia June 9th it
remains to be seen but buy tickets I'll
give you a full refund if I don't show
up christycomedy.com for tikiwickies
guys I want to tour with the Jokers
right now speaking of new episodes every
Thursday night at 10 on TBS and True TV
and then we're going to Bangor Maine uh
three at the Wang April 28th and 29th in
Boston we got the Maverick Center in
Utah on May 5th the Bellco Theater in
Denver on May 6th then we're going to
Arlington uh we're going to Austin Texas
The Moody Center Sugar Land uh that's
May 19th 20th and 21st we're gonna keep
going going to Columbus we're going to
Cleveland going to Detroit Minneapolis
Des Moines Kansas City Nashville
Indianapolis St Louis it's all up there
we're also adding dates so if you don't
see your dates you just go back and
check we're adding it's
impracticaljokerslive.com for all the
tickets I love you God bless you
foreign
[Music]
against his head pull my trigger now
he's dead
mama Mama
life has just begun but now I've gone
and thrown it all away
mama
[Music]
didn't mean to make you cry
if I'm not back again this time tomorrow
carry on carry on cause nothing really
hey babes
Jay Larson is our guest do you like my
sweatshirt
I mean what do you think of that I don't
even I mean what is that for it looks
like that's from like the World Baseball
Classic I know it does you know I mean
1999 World Series sweatshirt that's one
with the 1986 World Series logo who lost
two I can't I don't even remember that
what was that look even even the way he
talks it just popped out he's like I
don't even [__] Red Sox that
that's how uh you know
just give me one of those did they yeah
nice like that Mitchell Ness I was like
thank you so much
can I just say this like I'm walking
around by like the memorial and I see
like guys with brand new Yankee hats on
they just got because they come to the
city and there's two fans they're what
flagrant too if they're fans of the
flagrant two podcasts it's just the most
iconic symbol for uh you know what I
mean yeah and it just represents the
city and I started thinking there's in
my high school yearbook there's a
picture of me wearing a Yankee hat oh
like man if that ever gets out was it
like a prank no man you know why because
Donnie baseball Mattingly was my guy
that was my guy number one so you felt
growing up in Boston being a Boston Red
Sox fan that it was okay to even wear a
Yankees anything even if you liked a
player from their team well it's like
this as a Celtics fan growing up you
always uh respected the Lakers even
though that was our rival but like the
you know you loved everyone that played
for the Lakers so the same with the
Yankees man like you could not love
Donnie baseball he put the eye black and
he was hunched over the Lefty and he
raked just a good guy he's my number two
all-time favorite Yankee who's the
number one number one he's not he's not
an original he he came over from another
team oh whatever in the when they
started when they started winning like
late not Scott brochure Scott Brosius
looks like he should be like teaching oh
no but
no David he's a position player David
Justice no a lot of David's no no no no
top five from the Cincinnati Reds yep
everybody's mom's favorite if you had a
white Suburban mother she she diddled it
to Paul O'Neill he reminds me of my dad
a little bit as did Gary Carter you know
what my favorite is
my favorite man of all time my only only
man I really loved of all time
I have love for two Rangers oh
team no oh favorite goalie of all time
and Rick Lundquist no
Richter John Van beesberg
and came over from another team not the
second guy did hockey's a stretch Thomas
sandstrom came over from the Kings wow
two of my favorite my favorite hockey
player of all time Cal Clutterbuck
I think he's still in the Islanders oh
that's why I don't know him I stopped
watching oh
is
he's The Islander he is The Islander
yeah he's only only played I think the
player of all three New York teams
LaFontaine is a nice last name it's a
great name because you don't know is it
Italian is it French that's French it's
French right yeah Jay knows I mean come
on we all know we knew anyway my Paul
O'Neill would you remember that time in
right field and he was going towards the
middle and Bernie Williams coming over
and instead of like turning around 30 he
flicked it to Williams to throw it and
he's just like amazing what everyone
talks about that Jeter when he when he
catches that play at home yeah that Paul
O'Neill play was just amazing also you
loved it he he broke his Bat when he
couldn't leg out a single yeah you know
what I mean it was unbelievable yeah he
had great long legs
Bernie Williams by the way is my
favorite baseball player of all time
because I support the Puerto Ricans
but you know him personally I uh no well
I've met him personally through this
when I first time I met him
um
I uh tear it up because it was childhood
memories 51 was always my favorite
player remember my dad wanted my
favorite player to be Donnie baseball
Don Mattingly but I was a new era I was
10 years old I was like no I like these
Yankees I like the guy who plays
classical guitar yeah exactly yeah oh so
you didn't
baseball in 1996. no yeah that was my
first that I was 12. oh my God you just
blew my balls so that's so that I only
ever remember the Yankees being a
dynasty oh see I started in about 86. so
the Yankees were like the worst team in
baseball forever they would yeah they
weren't even making the freaking
playoffs
from the from their last World Series
appearance I think in 83 versus Dodgers
I think it was 81-83
um they didn't make the playoffs until
96 I'm sorry 95 Don Manley's last year
the year they got in squeaked in for the
Wild Card lost in the first round to
Seattle Ken Griffey Jr slid home
right to win the game didn't Ken Griffey
Jr yeah for the run to win the game I I
vividly remember yeah vaguely remember
that so so there goes then Donnie
baseball retires next year begins the
dynasty Dynasty 96 97
no not 97 96 98 99 2000 2003 right yeah
and then we got to the Red Sox Dynasty
is you guys
2000 yeah but 2003
2003 you beat us in in after we were up
3-0 that was 2000 that was 2004. wasn't
it we won it was before 2000 Red Sox
came back from 3-0 that was their first
year that was their one was 2003. curse
breaking or 2003 the Florida Florida oh
okay you know what happened in 2004 when
we were down three Zips that was the
fight when you guys were killing us in
the third game I was at a bar with the
girl I was dating I was so let down I
looked around like I love you and she
was like she didn't say it back the next
night she comes over my house and I'm
watching game four we're in extras and
she comes over and I'm laying there and
I'm watching the game like intensely I'm
like hey and she goes hey she goes I've
been thinking about what you said I'm
like yeah she's like I love you too I'm
like all right all right
right now yeah yeah I was just so dead
from that do you remember those Rings
those games were I mean the city shut
down for those games so you only so so
you were 12 but I was like in college
sophomore in college dude I mean do you
know what happened I went to the Yankees
parades I went to all the parades you
did of course you did you get parade in
your blood of course baby did you see
you for Columbus baby yeah and I'm
Puerto Rican so we got the parade uh did
you see what the streets were like when
they won oh yeah in 96. yeah it was wild
dude people were just it was like Philly
like it was like it was like people
crazy it was crazy I yeah Sports
unfortunately now I don't know if it's
just the world or whatever but no sport
it it doesn't take over like that
anymore it doesn't take over our lives
it doesn't take over my life which is
sad do you find yourself wishing to go
back to the 90s I'm finding myself all
constantly wishing to go back to
Childhood oh yeah you always want to go
back to like 2007. yo why what was those
seven well no because because
I'm bringing it I want to go by any
amount of time but if I'm if I'm being
honest it's 80s no well wait of my
lifetime because I wanna I always wanted
to [__] around in the 50s what but I'm
going if I'm going back to my lifetime
it's 80s 90s okay because the reason why
I'm asking is because we're all
different ages right yeah so I'm
wondering like I when I think about like
just like if I'm like not feeling good
or whatever and I'm just like take me
back to a time that was dope for me it
was like 2 000 like three four five six
like everything just was easy but I was
also like 21 years old and yeah guys but
is it is it the same like are my kids
gonna be like you know when they're
older get back I wish I could take it
back to 2032.
the world just better in 20 years ago
than it is today I think it was what's
the answer I think it was better okay
everyone's better Jay I will I recently
read this article that your brain 80 of
the time is living in nostalgia eighty
percent of the time if you let your
brain go it goes backwards it always
wants to go to the Past always eighty
percent we have a reason why I just
think it's comfortable you know it like
if you think about people's fear in life
it's anything that's in front of them
because they don't know what's next are
they going to lose their house do they
have money especially now like people
financially so 80 of the time you it's
so easy to just go back and live in the
past flush my file away the good the
good times are all there excessively
right there for you let them roll early
20s bro you don't have a worry in the
world right you're not thinking about a
401k you don't have kids you're not
you're not worried about what's next
okay so do you think like when I'm
saying like my best years or even like
the late 90s like sometimes I think
about is it just a pre-911 world like
when I I'll YouTube New York City 1999
just to see what it was like people
every streets packed everyone walking
around and I'm thinking man I loved I
was 15 loved it back then but do you
think my father was sitting there in
1999 being like I'm gonna lose
everything I'm gonna lose this mother
I'm gonna lose house which all came true
do you think he's like oh [__] my life
is over yes so because that's just what
we do not over you just go back yeah but
is it a sliding scale or have we reached
a point now of no return where
everything's just hum just saturated
what do you got
you did it you personally did you
persevered that's commitment can't stop
won't stop go hard or go home that's
what we preach here all day I say it's
sliding scale bro yeah I think you're
always going to find something that you
love back then but it's never just going
to be like I mean you're never gonna be
able to take your kids pre-internet when
life was just like free internet is what
it is that's free internet okay so
that's what we're getting into that boom
so you think then as we're living
through it that the internet is worse
for us than better
yeah it's a double-edged dildo the
internet because you think if the
internet collapsed right now it
collapsed and I'm not talking about the
[__] one bot it's [__] somebody
that's giving the other person plus you
don't you know you don't know do you
think of a life better
the internet
we've lived through two major things the
internet I mean 911 is huge but globally
I mean globally it affected the world
but the pandemic the pandemic affected
the world and we're gonna look back at
this and it's gonna be like everything
pre and post pandemic completely post
911 yeah way more than the pandemic
affected the entire Globe every single
person 911 did not right you know what I
mean I know we're like a stone's throw
from the memorial I sat over there
before you have to NY just pulled up
like what the [__] do you say
yo 911 I mean that was the only year
I've ever been like watching the World
Series and pulling for the Yankees like
win this [__] game
comedy in L.A in 2001 shows shut down
when the games were on everybody was
watching everybody wanted the Yankees I
mean it is interesting that I do think
too like this this pre and post pandemic
I'm actually in a way I used to say when
we're going through it oh it sucks that
my kids are going through this but now
I'm actually thankful because they are
not going to remember the war they only
will live in a post-pandemic world which
I think is better where if you were like
18 going through this you're like damn I
know like you're like they're like us
we're like you know what the world used
to be but like my daughter she's seven
she's like oh the world was everybody
always had Mass on uh it's fine
like the kids we were so worried about
them with the mass and this and that
they like they just adapted they were
like this is just what I you know oh
these kids my I have a I have a I guess
nibbling I say nibbling it's my is that
a racial slur yeah man nibblings bro you
adopted a nibbling oh wow you're
Progressive no so like my dog my sister
has a child who is they them they go by
they them okay and I say to my kids we
send them a birthday like message and I
tell the kids I'm like well you know
they go by they them not she or he they
them and they just go oh okay yeah that
was it it was over yeah they've said
they them since it doesn't even register
they don't have the capacity to be like
oh why is this could this be a problem
societal pressure they're just like
whatever you tell me to do years and
years and years well they also didn't
hear it for 40 years like us where like
every time I have to be like
they are and they're like I'm like well
you know you know what I mean like that
so they don't grow up with a grandpa
that fought in Vietnam
or World War II or World War II right
right right well to be honest Iraq yeah
yeah do you know that when I was a
physical therapist the fit when I was a
physical therapist I wish I could say
that to people you know when I was a
physical therapist come here let me see
your back let me see your back I I
remember working at the um uh the
hospital uh what's it called um
the name of the hospital Fort Wayne
Memorial yes the the name of the
hospital the place within us where where
veterans go veterans
that's what it was Veterans Hospital the
Veterans Hospital veterans veterans
affairs maybe veterans I don't know but
they should call it a [__] dump
because they do nothing at the beach
and that's why you're voting 20 24
matters if you want to see change
um so
they them so I I
remember
working with them working with the
veterans and the veterans from World War
II would call the veterans in Vietnam
[__] and then the veterans of Vietnam
would call the veterans from Iraq
[__] and they all had this like they
all have this like um fighting going on
because like World War II guys were like
yeah I killed Nazis with my bare hands
what did you do [__] you know light a
Vietnamese person on fire from a
helicopter whoop-dee-doo and then the
Iraqi guys are like you guys didn't do
anything you just push buttons you
didn't even [__] see the enemy in the
face like all these things I was like
guys guys guys you're all you're all you
all have spring none of you have legs
yeah like like you're all you're all
[__] just torso but you roll out of
here yeah
yeah yeah I I I I really hoped that they
were heated in that argument and said
whoop-dee-doo yeah
would you throw Obama yeah
yeah you do whoopty do yeah what was
that like working did you really work in
the VA yeah yeah it was what I will say
at least the veterans that I worked from
old to new were on they are unbelievable
people to work with I work with some
people who are you know didn't sustain
any problems they just you know got old
had diabetes or whatever but then I
worked with a couple of guys who got
like hurt in the war first of all this
is how bad the VA is someone's got
diabetes they send them to the physical
therapist what the [__] what are you
doing yeah what are you doing how's your
insulin guys I don't even know what this
is well for that well if those guys if
they didn't have a foot or if they were
like needed to get like some type of
like um sensation back in their body
then we would do things to try but I
don't think it really worked but
um but I remember like they would have
like dark [__] jokes and like they
would like laugh at their experience
like a lot of times like I remember one
time I remember the guy is two Iraq
veterans
um and they were you know must have been
in they were in there for a long time
and they I guess one of them had said
said that the Ravens were going to win
the Super Bowl that year and they had
they didn't win and they had or I think
that year they had come in like they had
a really bad season but they were like
supposed to win and I remember they were
just talking whatever and the one guy
was like I said the Ravens were gonna
win the Super Bowl but you know and the
other guy was like I guess you were
wrong he goes yeah he goes I'm wrong
about a lot of things I stepped on a
land mine and he had no leg Yeah Yeah
and it was like what but he just and
then they're both laughing they're like
of course they're like they [__] bury
them and then they started talking about
how deep the land much better goes
they're [__] good at that [__] and
they started talking about how the enemy
was good at landmines and I'm like what
guys but they're but they're just
they're because they're like hey man
this is what my life is so that's wild
yeah I did uh I did a tour of Iraq doing
like stand up and the great the greatest
joke told the whole time I'm doing a
show in like this like base and a guy
leaves in the middle of my set like they
gotta go they have duties at like 9 30
at night you know so this guy's walking
out I'm like you're gonna walk out on me
why don't you walk out of me and then
like he stopped at the end I go you see
that you see that power I have over him
and he just goes and Cox's gun the whole
place falls out like whatever he was
like that's a boy
crushed it you would like shoot me shoot
me and he did he just [__] he's like
watches everybody they're like good chat
yeah [__] babe Babble yeah the
language learning app I'm using Babble
it is amazing they literally what they
do is it's it's almost like they teach
you the word and then they kind of quiz
you on it yeah and it's it literally you
start to form words you start I'm
thinking in Italian
whoa you must have been using battle
Yeah ciao in all seriousness 14
languages a language learning app it
makes bite size lessons makes learning
fun and you could really want to be
learning less uh a new language because
you're going on a vacation somewhere
because you want to communicate with a
friend or relative whatever because yeah
for whatever reason 14 different
languages and it was created by 150
language experts no AI none of that
stuff this is real people with using the
speech recognition technology which
helps improve your pronunciation and
accents it's not just
uh it's not just the lessons right they
have podcast games video those stories
they even have live classes live classes
chess permanentarity plus a 20-day
money-back guarantee start it right now
all you got to do is go to Babel that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com hey babe and you're
gonna get 55 off your subscription when
you go to babble.com hey babe sign up
for 55 off your subscription go to do it
don't do it online because I did it
online and then I got the app so you get
the service in it was just a little bit
easier for me so go to the actual search
engine put in babel.com hey babe you can
see that discount come up and it's great
and it's and it's language learning for
Life Bible language
um yeah but Jay Larson is here from L.A
you have a
it's coming out 419 I don't know when
this is going to air 419. before 4 19. I
like 419 because everyone goes 420 you
win a day before and I I respect thank
you yeah yeah I like that so it'll this
will either be out uh just right before
or just right after that right pimpy so
but we've got to make sure it might be
coming out a couple days Jay Larson
comedy on YouTube so YouTube Jay Larson
comedy youtube.com slash Jay Larson
comedy and that's l-a-r-s-e-n Owen Owen
said it wrong on purpose so you
remembered it more that's a tactic I
like your style you say it wrong because
I knew that it was oh and I was a
licensed physical therapist that you
know that it's wrong and then you say it
wrong and then it doesn't matter if
people like you dumb [__] it gets people
talking and that's how you think it's a
mistake sometimes is actually the
correct thing to do one time when I was
in grammar school they were talking
about
it's already alive I was I didn't go to
Ground School I I taught myself yeah
homeschooled uh we were talking about
the like uh the court system yeah and
law and whatever how do you do in
grammar school grammar school well
whatever was came up and I was like can
I ask you a question and I said when
when they say something not supposed to
say and then someone objects uh and then
they and then I said but then like it's
not allowed but they said it anyway so
the jury heard it right so it makes
sense so like maybe they're just saying
it because they want the jury to hit you
know they know it's going to be
objective and the teacher went now
you're getting it interesting that is
deep dude and I was like oh it's smart
yeah that's that's smart and then and
then because yeah because I remembered
it A Few Good Men Tom Cruise did it a
bunch yeah yeah I just didn't know if
the colonel was aware of that you know
they're like objections
yeah I don't know because when they say
the jury to not be biased by like what
they hear outside it's like no but you
will you're a human being what are you
talking about yeah it's like oh don't
watch the Netflix documentary about this
case it's like I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna
watch I'm watching it on my phone right
now I'm gonna go with the opinion of the
director I don't care I wouldn't want to
get sequestered with you now sequestered
means what I think it means like almost
like they you you oh sequestered like
you get called in for jury duty yeah but
is it also sequestered like
they got to go report back to the hotel
room and they can't watch the news yeah
once you're on once you're on a jury
then you're like but the way to get a
jury duty is just say that you're biased
or racist or homophobic and then they
they cannot pick you just say that
you're what or don't even say that
whatever they say it beat up outside the
courthouse no but say but say you're
going in for um you know somebody fell
and broke their ankle I did it on a
thing and a sidewalk say ah you know
what my uncle broke his ankle it was a
sad turnout then you don't and then
they'll just be like okay great and then
but that you're crossed off because you
have a bias yeah I did it I had a guy in
the Box commit to our felonies I had a
guy involved in an accident I didn't
want to go to Georgia and I just said I
was hit by a car when I was younger but
that's true yeah it was true and I said
and I said I didn't get nearly as much
as I thought I deserved and I think that
the system you know it's not meant to to
Really to you know to give me the to pay
out the proper amount and they were just
like you're out when's the last time you
went to jury duty I haven't been in 10
years I've never gone you've never gone
you've never gotten called I've gotten
called
but you never got had to actually go
no need to come out of the bullpen I
just I'm just there was one I think I
went once but I I don't even think that
was for jury duty I think that was for I
was had to go to court but I've gotten
the thing so many times and I'm just I'm
like I don't have time for it bro and
you don't even respond no and they don't
say anything I've gotten some things
before everybody doesn't respond you get
that fifth or sixth notice where they
say they're gonna take you home and
everything yeah and then you then you
respond because I feel like they must be
sending mine to the wrong address they
might have the wrong address I haven't
gotten one in a while let's send it to
the VA for you bro when I voted I was
like this is gonna this is gonna wake
him up they're gonna send me the fact
that I voted but like uh I did that one
time then the next time I went I had
just been the show had just started okay
and I walked and I just said can I just
level with you please like it's like
they had us sitting there all day
waiting to be called to see so it's the
second two days straight just sitting
amongst people waiting to be called to
see if you'd be on the jury and I just
went up to somebody and I was like can
you do me a favor I'm I'm on I'm in the
public and I feel really uncomfortable
and everyone's coming up to me and they
were just like no they stamped me in the
city good for seven years wow and that
but that was seven pluses I'm I'm up so
you got sequestered for seven years no
no could you imagine oh my God yeah
what's the longest the case could go
three months it can go yeah no I thought
it was in-depth
no you can't be indefinitely you think
well well no I mean not like murder
trials can go yeah so what happens to
the jury they have a new life
look however one rule of thumb is eight
months
that's asking a lot
but did you get paid you get paid but
not what you get paid you get paid their
wage their wage which is not fair but
here's the thing too that I was thinking
about with the jury if it's like a
really like let's say a murder case and
I'm sure he's not sure he's not sure
it's kind of like as a human your
humanness of you your individual
narcissism that we all have takes over
you're like I don't care what happens to
this person I want to get out of here
right so I'm going to vote guilty even
though I don't think he's guilty to get
the [__] out of it or vote not guilty
just so I can leave so there has to be
something to prevent that I think once
you're in there you're getting wrapped
up and it doesn't you think so I was
gonna say what percentage 40 a day
for jury duty it's insane you could
still tell everyone like no one's in
there that 40 a day is better than what
they were doing you know what I mean so
everybody wants to get out but I think
once you're in it you're like I'm here
let's do a fair trial that's my civic
duty yeah I think you're just like it'd
be like a rush you'd be like this is
dope like let's just do this I think
they have sex back in the hotel room
like you think there's a love affairs
that go on with the jury and get to know
each other in a fantasy world yeah they
definitely do right but I don't think
they're allowed to I think it's illegal
to have sex with a fellow jury member I
don't think you can have like a hotel
room but see let's see him stop I don't
think he's gonna see him stop me I'm
sure it's happened in life right I think
I would go in there and I'd be like I
have them I have to uphold my morals I
have a civic duty and I will and it
might be interesting to be on like a
like a like a crazy trial yeah but I
can't go on social media yeah no they
can't do a thing how would they stop you
I could do my podcast
because once you're on social media you
can see things coming up if their trial
people can be hitting you up people can
get at you oh it's impossible they're
gonna have to change the legal system
break up a family they could break up a
family if you get sequestered for an
eight-month trial and you know how to do
anything like and you're making forty
dollars a day your whole family's gonna
tank yeah not you but like I mean you
know what I'm saying it what eight month
trial though you walk out of there with
like a book deal you know what I mean
yeah you do
I'm not going to Australia
we were talking about would you go to
Australia you're going on a tour no I
would I you got to go for a minute
though that's what I'm saying I'm not
going I don't want to go I want to
cancel I want to just not go to
Australia even though I love the people
of Australia I don't want to go because
you're going to miss your family so much
yeah I don't want to be on this side of
the world in my family and it's I'll
lose my it's like you know you know this
Australian dollar none of it I I just
why not just stay here we at the end
they started muttering about currency
the Australian currency
you get paid in Australian dollars it's
not the same so if you make x amount
Australian dollars that's not US Dollars
oh so what's just like in the UK so
what's the what's the thing right now
let's see if it's worth the conversion
rate
yeah but they're not paying you your
rate so you're that's you're making
money no that no no I'll lose money if I
got two grand Australia right it's only
6 800 us right
I gotta pay 20 of the Commission in
[__] Australian yeah but how many
shows you doing how long are you gonna
be there supposedly uh
no like 10 days you're paying for hotel
and accommodation they pay for that I
gotta pay for my opener though flight
and hotel out there that's a flight is
the nut what is that like 8K for that
flight
if you find Biz yeah I mean that's by
the way which I would never even guess
that also never consider going my coach
I won't go you can't go coach you can't
do that to yourself that's why I know
when so I can afford to go that way my
friend had to go last minute for work
and they had to put him up and it was
his contract to get a and his first
class flight one way was 16 Grand wow
it's it's no joke that flight was it 14
hours yeah or more 20 hours from New
York 22. but I just don't want to be on
the other side of the world for my
family I I I just I don't know I just
don't want to do it but but then people
are like it's a opportunity of a
lifetime I'm like but we live in a world
now where I could just go put into
YouTube walking tour of Sydney and feel
it I've done it I can't just do that you
can't okay
a month away from your kids I've never
done I think the longest I've ever I
mean I only got my kids I had two as
well big family guy so that's what I'm
saying I I the longest I've been away I
think has been like seven days maybe
eight days and it it gets to be tough
but I mean if you're looking as a work
opportunity and it's a really good
opportunity being in Australia is the
same as if you were in [__] Texas
versus New York it's a flight away you
know there's like nothing you're gonna
be able like what is the worst case
you'll miss them you can FaceTime them
dude think about we're talking about the
guys in World War II they're away from
their family for two years you are a
[__] murdering people these guys the VA
would tear you apart they're like oh you
[__] Australia you [__] so the only
thing that I could do then is what I
must do then is go to Australia to kill
Nazis that's the only way to rectifies
it if I'm going there with the purpose
of killing Nazis then I'm the same as a
world
so wait is he swaying you now
Sway in the Morning
um this is just your anxiety you're
gonna go no matter what you're just
gonna be no that's the thing is that's
the thing the thing is is I'm really
like my agent can't believe that I'm
even considering not going I'm like yeah
but if you put yourself in my shoes even
though I love the people of Australia
what is the incentive for me going other
than an experience to go I'm not gonna
be my kids I'm gonna lose money and and
I'm I'm I'm not I'm I'm just gonna be
it's I'm gonna be gone for two weeks
when I don't when I want to get off the
road I want to I Don't Wanna I wanna
cancel the rest of my dates even though
I I just don't want to go leave anymore
I know I'm just burnt down I don't want
to do it I've made enough money already
that are like I I I'm my family start
thinking about that my family's like we
have what we want what the [__] am I
doing here yeah it's a good point you
know and it's a weird job because that's
the job and that's the job till the end
exactly so you're going to be doing this
until I mean Comics go until they die
yeah that's what happens pretty much if
you know they go until they die so the
travel is never leaving you had we had
to make a decision it was like an actual
decision because if you want to stay
where you are if you want to stay with
the momentum that you have yeah you can
like dip out and then come back and do
shows here and there whether you'll sell
the same amount of tickets or not who
knows at your leisure and maybe you want
to go get up on stage and do spots to
get something just to feel the feeling
but like at some point we either have to
say I'm done with this
or I'm going to keep doing this or or
you move to another state where there's
no like you moved to Florida that's why
people do it you just save
maybe four months worth of shows in
state tax you just don't pay it so we
have to pay a rental fee to New York we
just pay a rental fee to live in this
[__] state so yeah it's been ruined
by the you know who's yeah the Nazis no
the Nazis no it's the uh nibblings
they are ruining everything yeah um
you're saying move to Florida do half
the shows is that what you're saying no
I'm saying if we lived in Florida yeah
right or Texas or Texas if we lived in
Florida or Nashville or Tennessee well
Tennessee has a little but Florida is
zero okay if if and Texas is zero you
whatever you paid
I know say say say a million bucks you
made a million bucks we have to pay I
think it's 18 of that
two I know it on every million to the
state of New York just for living here
where you would if you made a million
bucks in Florida the same million bucks
you were just putting 180 000 back in
your pocket for oh simply because you
don't you you live in a state where we
have to [__] I have to pay rent to
live in the state it's unbelievable and
then
why did Rogan move you know he shaved
like 15 million dollars a year on his
taxes yeah he didn't need I mean we're
talking about a different but then again
you're talking about how much money do
you need you don't think Rogan's kids
would be like Dad we got it we're good
bro you don't need it the 15 of the 150.
right so you're looking at Big first of
all the only reason you go to Australia
is to grow your audience and they want
to see you live so you show up for them
and then they you extend their fandom
towards you for years by showing up
there you go Theory it's truth
everywhere you go it's like but don't
you think you have through our through
our digital world no you don't it's a
different story when you I just posted a
story today on my Instagram that I'm in
New York and people like where you going
up are you doing show they the idea that
they get to see you live in their Town
even if it's for a short time that's
that's why you do it you're not doing it
for the the money you already want to
see him so he's not growing it
if I waited five years they'd become a
bigger fan he's assuaging it out of
sight is out of mind bro you know I mean
you can have fans over there they watch
the Pod sure but you go over there they
buy merch they they sign up maybe you
know
I'm back in
I'll put money down right now that you
should do it we should do a poll
we should pull our fans should I go
no no
should I go we should bet whether we
think you're gonna oh okay we should
yeah and we should bet is whatever Chris
cancel when I do cancel is that
announcement real or fake Chrissy cancel
he's right around the corner so
everybody should I stay or should I go
who sings it
I'm gonna take a genuine guess truly
do I stay or do I go this is a real
truth true to the hard guess I don't
know much about music but I'm gonna say
should I stay or should I go is by
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
I love it we love it that's what Adele's
the song Hello that's what it's about
yeah they made her cut out the fresh
right because they did a focus group on
it right and people thought that it was
too wordy right but we here are pro
we're pro Adele we're pro hello fresh
and if you're not a pro in the kitchen
that was pretty sick that was like
insane put in you should send them copy
you should send them hello fresh is
foolproof recipes arrive pre-portioned
and easy to prepare in just a few steps
hellofresh keeps your taste buds you
have a show called taste I do on your
toes I have a show called toes nice with
40 recipes and over 100 seasonal and
convenience items to choose from each
week with so much variety there are
options for everyone in every lifestyle
doesn't you you could be a professional
parkour person they got a meal for you
look it comes right to your door okay
it's the warmer weather is coming spend
more time outside less time cooking less
time at the grocery store indoors you
know what I'm saying and all you got to
do right now is go to hellofresh.com hey
babe50 and use the code hey babe 50 for
50 off plus your first box ships free
one more time to tell them Sal sure you
go to hellofresh.com hey babe five zero
and you use the code hey babe50 for 50
off plus the first box ships free you
know we love hellofresh if you haven't
tried it yet you gotta just try it
there's no harm in that the deal is
amazing hellofresh America's number one
meal kit I gotta tell you right now I am
a guy I'm a guy that loves to go to a
live event you are I love a sporting
event I love a concert a lot of live
music I love the theater right and you
don't have a way to get like tickets and
all that easy well I'm always whenever
I'm the guy that's like what I'm the guy
that listens to when the pre-sale starts
I'm the guy that's like okay the Gen
because I always want the best seats and
I want to be ahead of the curve right so
for someone like me game time is the
place for Less that's the one that you
use well I at this time it's the best
because if you don't get it right in the
front when it's pre-sale that's it you
feel like you're hopeless not true
because with game time you can get the
best last minute tickets right the
killer deals on the last minute the best
price guarantee and they got everything
sports music comedy whatever you want
they got it so forget months at planning
in advance like that you can look up
tonight what's going on in your city and
then hit up game time you get those and
you know what they do you get images of
your seat before you buy so you know
exactly what to expect when you arrive I
like that you can get tickets in a
matter of seconds two Taps and you're
set what about this if you find tickets
in the same section of row for Less game
time will credit you 110 of this that's
insane so you know you're getting the
best game time for that yeah I actually
want to go out and seek it I'm going to
seek the other price so I can get free
tickets plus 10 right now snag the
tickets without stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account use the code hey babe twenty
dollars off your first purchase term
Supply again create an account and
redeem the code hey babe twenty dollars
off download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed but I'm
gonna say should I stay or should I go
is by The Beatles Don't Say
can I guess three I want three because
I'm not a big music guy either it's
either Violent Femmes The Kinks or uh
what's that band from New York Queens
it's not though the romance but it's not
it's not the Ramones it's not who'd you
say The Kinks no no Violent Femmes no
one more guess
um the band that sings um uh Monday I'm
in love with you the Cure The Cure not
the Cure
I think it is should I stay or should I
go is it Jane's Addiction no it's not
Jane's Addiction what do we got pimp
it's older than that The Clash The Clash
I was close with the Kinks when he said
cure I thought you meant Clash yeah
that's it that's their poppy song so
that's not like if you like really love
the Clash you don't really love that
song but uh The Clash but the reason I
had cure on the Mind actually is because
they're playing the garden yes in the
garden uh soon and I've never seen them
I gotta go see them by the way so am I
the Hulu theater September 23rd which is
not the real Garden but it is in the
building of the mountain Square Garden I
just want to be clear with my fans it is
not I I know it is not the real Garden
but I am there September 23rd September
22nd Radio City sold out to December
23rd I'm not going to Australia
you I know what's happening you're not
going I know you I know you're not going
I know you're not going you know I want
to go though I just want to put out the
energy out there to my fans in Australia
I do want to go but I don't know if I
physically
I don't know if I could do it so I might
be adding shows in Pittsburgh or
something in June I love it yeah it's
just so just just be close to home yeah
what are you doing uh volcanic eruption
you
yeah and then it goes uh into the
stratosphere nobody can fly across the
world
didn't put that in my head wow
something to think about yeah yeah you
met Robertson they could get in get in
the way yeah I've met Robert Smith
really what was he like he was dope he's
wearing a Bruins Jersey it was a great
wood he was wearing a Bruins Jersey
Robert Smith for the show in Boston yeah
and I would like I got backstage where
you got to meet and stuff and I was like
gave him a poster sign and he was just
like
you know it's like cool man my sister
won tickets off the radio and I was in
college she's like I'd [__] out of
schools at home she goes you want these
tickets you saw them back then I called
my boy BC I'm like hey you want to go to
see the Cure he goes yeah we drove up
with beers in the back of our car smoked
a joint in the parking lot winning
met Robert Smith [__] Mary kill Robert
Smith Robert Plant Robert E Lee
Jesus Christ [__] Mary kill Robert Smith
Robert Plant Robert E Lee
you marry Robert Plant okay
you got access to that whole category
okay that whole you get like a horse got
that in the divorce yeah
Robert now Robert E Lee are you married
are you killing Robert E Lee are you
marrying Robert Smith are you killing
Robert Smith let me just put a let me
just put it out there that Robert E Lee
okay the the head of the Confederate
Army the general was yes fighting for
the Confederacy the bad guys pieces of
[__] but but he did say I'm only
fighting for them because of of
geography and where I live and where my
heart is in Virginia and I must fight
with them even though I don't agree with
everything that they stand for we kill
him okay I think he [__] that dude you
don't think he's like good he must be
intense in bed bro Confederate soldiers
definitely [__] better than Union
Soldiers that's what I'm saying you know
I'm only here because I want to be here
yeah no because I don't I don't want to
be here no but with that attitude I
don't want to be here
[Laughter]
all right I don't know but Robert Smith
you don't want to you don't wanna I kind
of want to just be pen pals or something
yeah it'd be intense to live with that
guy yeah you know I mean every day is
just like what does guys do like um
these guys that have such an image like
that at home are they still walking
around and like uh Old Navy pajamas and
just like you know what I mean like
like people like like a like the Tim
Burton types like Robert Smith like
these goth like a Marilyn Manson like at
home you know that like you walk in the
house and the guy's wearing like a met
t-shirt right okay I'm asking you like
because they they they have such an
image like a a rock star image you know
what I mean like all these people that
have like they only show themselves in
in this kind of stress like it's Ozzy
Osbourne just you know yeah in like
flannel pajamas or something I think
they're chill yeah don't you think they
have another side I I think I gotta well
I think that what's interesting about
these people like this like a Tim Burton
or Ozzy Osbourne all these guys Robert
Plant they are really only those people
for an hour of the day like when we see
them outside on the in the concert you
think so yeah what else the other days
they're brushing their teeth they're
taking chips or having anxiety they're
talking about ghosts they're they're
just ready
well I still dress like that yeah
they're contemplating Australia they are
I do think somebody like a Tim Burton
well like his homeless pimp does he have
sunflower pants on if you just go in the
house is he dressed like that he does uh
yeah yeah you always have something on I
also think with this question their soul
is so cool that they kind of carry that
in any outfit interesting you're more of
an entity
yeah yeah their soul is so cool how
often do we like look at someone's Soul
you know when's the last time you looked
at somebody saw I'm looking at I'm
looking at one right now too this guy's
got one of the best of all time
but you're saying so he opens his closet
and he's like all right there's 50 pairs
of leather pants which one like you're
saying when he's walking he's like I got
oh I got a spring clean today okay I'm
gonna shake the toaster out today
he's wearing he's wearing Leathers
leather pants
put something in in the aura in my head
that I never considered that there it's
their soul so it's not that he's doing
this for us he's really doing it for him
he is who he is and he will always be
that guy all the time he's not a fraud
if he was a fraud he'd be able to see
right through we could catch him on that
[__] but you can't let's shift it
then to like someone like the president
like Obama right cool guy president for
eight years like I mean he's a human
being this there's a time where he's
running down the hole in the white house
because he has explosive diarrhea right
right then he just sits on the ball he's
like oh oh God thank god oh there's
there's times where like just think
about like yeah like right Joe Biden's
having sex
you don't think he's had sex since he's
been inaugurated president you think Joe
Biden has had sex with Dr Joe Biden I
don't know
how come Dr Joe Biden can't diagnose Joe
Biden why can't Dr Joe Biden fix Joe is
she a doctor she is Dr Joe Biden but
what kind of doctor she's I don't know
she's a doctor I trust her look at how
Obama looks good how hilarious is it
that she's a doctor and she still has to
be Dr Joe by get the [__] out of here
right you know what I mean that's crazy
so what was saying like does he ever go
okay okay okay ready look we're on the
road right okay we go back shows are
back in the hotel room throw on the TV
Mario Lopez comes on for a couple
seconds before we realize he's talking
right then we get our food over here you
know how you lay on your stomach on the
bed yeah laying your stomach out of bed
like this then you like you're like the
TV's yeah feet up your feet are up in
the end you're laying on your stomach
like this and maybe like you're eating a
salad and you're just like flipping and
so does Obama lay on his stomach on the
bed with his feet up yes 100 he does he
is as normal as you are you imagine an
hour or two a day truly can you imagine
your eyes saw Obama in his pajamas on
his stomach with his feet up with
holding his hands in his face watching
TV on the bed like that he might lose
control of the world yeah you can't show
that side let me tell you something
right now 100 for sure that man was
president in the United States for eight
years one thousand percent Secret
Service agents waiting outside the door
while he masturbated
one and then came out 20 minutes later
and gave a speech about he he isn't he's
a human being right he's masturbated in
the all in the white house right right
they all have right that whole place is
comfort and come right
you know if you think about it every
president has masturbated in the wife
they've all they've all they're humans
they're human beings they've all
mastered you think they're the only one
two best to be in the White House is the
White House also offices
yeah it's everything but it is also it's
also his residence yeah so there's
offices and Residences yeah so is there
a wing of like all offices and then his
own Wing well they're upstairs right the
living quarter is like second and then
they have the regular kitchen don't you
remember the the greatest Comedians in
Cars Getting Coffee was when he when
they went to the White House and Obama
takes Jerry likes out of the cafeteria
and he's like hey you want something
what do you want you want ice cream like
yeah just get whatever you want to get
up in the middle of the night okay and
yes and tiptoe down and eat a string
cheese yes yes
Saddam Hussein did it even
first of all he was jerking off a little
bit different than everybody else I got
a feeling
it's a secret serve outside the bathroom
or is it like he's in this door this
door has a lot in there this is the door
and everything he needs is in there
let's just cranking one out in the Oval
Office because it's like he's just tense
you know I guarantee you the stuff that
secret service would never tell us you
know Oaths or whatever you know Patriots
they I guarantee you they they have seen
presidents in or president's wives first
in very very very unflattering
compromised situations that they will
never say anything about it's not about
the documents they've seen you know
they've said to Obama answer your
penises he gets out of bed and nut falls
out of his box right yes before you go
did I say
no they say
they got the one they each have that one
guy first of all and then these guys
stay with them their whole lives yes
like George W bush right now is in
Austin or wherever he lives and he's got
Secret Service all around the property
yeah oh is he really I don't know he
said he was in oh yeah yeah he's doing
wrong but he's got those guys are with
him for the rest of their lives you know
but not the same guys just I'm sure they
have favorites like hey what do you
think do you want to like you want to
basically retire and just come up to
Maine like when George senior was living
in Maine we had family friends that were
like walking the beach in Maine and all
of a sudden Secret Service like oh you
guys got to stay here uh you know Mr
President walked on the beach he walked
down met them and he goes you want to
come back to the house and have tea like
went back to the house they had tea with
them and stuff and his wife you know are
you serious and they yeah and they'll
have Secret Service till the day they
die yeah and the kids like the Obama's
children have Secret Service with them
they're not going anywhere wild if they
came into the pond secret surf right by
the way offers out for the Obama girls
if they like to come do the podcast if
you are Obama if you are one of Obama's
Offspring if you you are one of Obama's
secret serve if you are a secret serve
and you're listening and we know that
you are please contact one of us and
come on the Pod right it's got to be a
secret service who's like detailed to
like the oldest living present at the
time he's got to be a bummer who's the
oldest is Jimmy Carter just passed away
just George Bush just passed away right
now he's the oldest living President
Clinton oh Carter is still alive I'm
sorry
youngest living Obama's 61. dude Obama
was present in his fort when Obama was
your age he was President of the United
States
that's correct yeah right yeah no became
president in 2008 as 2023 15 years he's
61. right for wow wow how old are you
Jay I'm 47. 47 Obama was already
president for a year divorce
he was
how old is Obama 46.
he's the 43rd and the 44th president
when he's 46. yes no he was just uh oh
yes he was the 43rd right before right
wow that's that's interesting you serve
two terms but then you still like if you
were President right you're the 50th
president but you're two terms you're
the 51st you should just be the it's the
same guy oh we're counting presents
we're counting bodies not terms yeah
terms
I don't want to say anything against
this great country that I love no you're
right so he was the 44th he was the 40th
third and 44th and then big and then the
four five DT and Now 46 JB
I I mean what's the most ridiculous
normal thing that you think that a
secret service agent has seen you don't
think they've ever heard them that's
having sex yes yes they have to protect
them they held the camera bro yeah
exactly patreon
but remember that was the whole thing
with like Obama which made him so
relatable remember when he like took
everyone to Five Guys like he went to
Five Guys like all right what do you
have again Jimmy it's like I got to get
so and he's like ordering Five Guys
because he was just like yeah I know
he's been a regular guy I know a guy who
interviewed him I know a guy I want to
say because it was probably probably but
I know a guy who interviewed him on the
last day he only granted two or three
interviews my friend the guy I know was
one of them padded fly balls he said
that last day that last day
of his last day of the presidency like
where he has gave the power to Trump
whatever he was on that day they had one
last night in the white house and he and
a couple of his crew like you know I
don't know if a secret service his wife
I don't know all smoked a blunt they
smoked weed on on the back balcony of
the White House just as and we're saying
goodbye come on that's how cool no my
friend was like what is it in the
leagues
but I'm immature am I immature or I'm
young at heart or I'm free spirit or
whatever you want to call it but if I
was the president you'd think that he's
like just
run down the hole in his socks and slid
yes I think he said yes
let him run and then slides yes and the
Secret Service is watching and then he
goes in there and then opens the door
and he's like push the button yeah he
probably fell down the stairs like an
[__] with a tray of cookies for his
kids like a dick and they had to just
you know be like all right we didn't see
that he is a smooth I mean that dude he
rips ass in the car and then says oh my
God lifts his leg up and rips forwards
and they die laughing all right they
can't even laugh yeah don't even laugh
don't even think about it correct you
know right right yeah you don't think
like the president too like you know
you're driving in the car whoever you
are Obama Trump bite and all of a sudden
it just starts telling dirty jokes to
the secret they're your men well we know
Trump does we know Trump does for sure
[Laughter]
but but but so it's like I think that I
think that it doesn't come along with
the other president a rock star whomever
we're all the same I think even
furthermore you ready for this yeah even
furthermore I think what's what's how
Obama was and we're blowing our mind
it's back maybe fell down the stairs
it's the same way Alexander the Great
was it's the same way George Washington
was that everybody's always been doing
the same things always I was in the
great ran down a hole and slid yes he
did he jerked off an elephant and
thought it was funny right they were
doing whatever the technology that was
available at their time and the joke
that they just found in in Sumeria which
is supposedly the first civil human
civilization but if you know if you're a
conspiracy theorist or you watched
ancient apocalypse on Netflix by Graham
Hancock you know that it wasn't but
let's go play the joke that Sumeria was
the first civilization in 5000 BCE is
what's BCE I don't know what the E stand
nobody knows I think we can find out
pretty quickly in BC bacon egg and
cheese I like it New York I go avocado I
switch the bacon for avocado I need good
fat before the Common Era so in BCE also
not before Christ when they found
writings ancient writing so is this a
way of saying before Christ that's not
religious Christ out of the equation
they found some of the earliest writings
that they found may not be the first
writings of all time the ones that were
discovered by by modern scientists they
were writing fart jokes they were
writing fart jokes on the Rocks that's
what they were doing so that's how they
related that's how their brains are so
why would it change anybody you've ever
heard anything they're all hacks
oh look at this hack carving [__]
yeah it must have been open mic this
night
and five thousand BC like women are bad
drivers we get it it's like come here
you time guys I want to bring you here
to see my car again
um all right so you think about that
with history but when do we start
recording December yesterday was history
what like when did they start like in
one they weren't like it's one no happy
New Year it's two so that's it I can't
start getting wrapped around that it
blows my mind but but well it just like
who was it I think it was Joe Mandy goes
just for like your for shits and giggles
understand that the alphabet is in no
particular order
who came up with the idea to put it in
order the alphabet but to put it in
order
or actually we have an Arabic alphabet
that's Arabic that outfit who wrote the
song
ABCDEFG classic dude I hope you have the
rights because you can't just throw that
out there yeah the Romans of course
Romans oh the Roman alphabet sorry about
that
um but I go the calendar the years that
those that was just decided that was
decided at a council it's called the
Council of nicaea they just decided
everything what years what year it was
uh what Jesus oh there were shepherds
around must have been this year someone
decided it's all it's all what one group
of men at that time decided was gospel
was truth but it may not be what
actually happened but when was that like
was someone saying 325 A.D is when the
Council of nicaea happened oh is that
right that's right that's correct so is
it that when they started calling at 325
so if they weren't religious then how do
they get how do they where how do they
Mark the before and after the Common Era
how do they get that that was that was
that was Julius Caesar the Julian
calendar that was the guardian Gregorian
the Gregorian chant okay
first developed as a lunar calendar my
man Julius Caesar 45 BC that's when 365
days with the leap year every four so
here's what I'm saying right it's 45 BC
how do they know in 45 BC it's 45 BC
because they're not counting down they
based it off when Jesus Christ died but
but it's 45 minutes I think they went
backwards even Jesus Christ you know
this the gospels that we take as Gospel
Matthew Mark Luke and John sure those
were written 50 years after Jesus died
imagine me trying to tell you a story
from 50 years ago that I wasn't even
[__] at that's crazy you're making
[__] up I know you're making [__] up for
50 years ago but what I'm saying is with
someone like dude
back in Thanksgiving uh 2000 back in
Thanksgiving four yeah yeah like how
would you remember Thanksgiving four
when I mean I I don't know when did we
start talking how do they know that the
[__] son is 365 billion because well
that's the whole that's why you have
science because if you look at it if
what if they got they just decided that
one day it was whatever right they them
yeah they them okay you know the niblets
let's just say they also decide oh we're
just going to make this day that and
then you know this might not even be a
Tuesday what day is it this could be a
Thursday who knows
what does it all matter time is not real
time is man it is a constructive man
sure it's just not the universe does not
go off time there is no time right but
the sun does rise and set but but yes
but it's not connected to any the time
the whole idea concept construct of time
is all made up sure none of it is so so
I'm not going to Australia
this guy I knew it was coming this has
been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe
[Music]